good evening I'm Alexander Rose the
director here at the long now foundation
and as some of you know we often do a
long short before these talks a short
film that exemplifies long term thinking
this months is a one of the rare ones
that I'm actually in last year just
about this time I went to small bar to
the 1,000 year global Seed Vault that is
has been installed above the 78th
parallel you can walk to the North Pole
and winter from there and I went there
with Stephen Ralph from Center for land
use interpretation and this is a short
film that that shows the the trip inside
and it actually coincides very well with
with Jim's work who is also there not
too long ago thank you
the challenges are enormous that we can
see we are filling up dearth quickly and
we have today bit more than seven
billion people and we will reach 9
billion people pretty soon we need to
feed all these people and FAO has
estimated that we need to increase for
agricultural production with 70% 70% up
to the year 2050 and that we should you
on the same area of land in the best
case with the same amount of water and
that is a very very big challenge not
saying that 20s it started with the 3d
banking and it spread all over the world
of the sixties and seventies things
happen indeed right today well those
genetic resources not only the field but
also in the gene banks because of simple
electricity failure a lack of money that
can be smaller catastrophes better
courses and so on which means that and
these inventing impacts have no backup
system no security storage somewhere
else which is important to have so we
have actually lost quite a bit over the
last couple years which means of the
backup system is very volatile and
that's why I think in a daddy for the
casino
to give up and they took some years
before there were community to accept
with a offer from Norway to build this
place today with off around little bit
less than 700,000 Dean makes the
Magnuson accession of seats office
representing two others and 28 countries
of the world and more than 4,000 plant
species so that's quite a bit but we
only have what is called plant genetic
resources for food and agriculture
there's no one in here this is
exclusively for food production
our forefathers have been them the plant
breeder have adapted material here even
if of Allah which comes from the Middle
East
no strands from here for six thousand
years ago and has been developed here
cause they see in the resources so
that's a ethnic problem
a political problem and everyone and can
you say just a little bit about the time
our idea of the timeline that will when
all the seats here will be or when they
will be needed the best in the best of
worlds the material here will never be
needed the same material his daughter in
loreen30 back under the same condition -
18 degrees in the same foreign banks as
here and there the contestants regularly
and if the germination even ability goes
down they can request their box back and
are all replacement material but as I
said in the best of world
please consider whatever
[Music]
you
good evening I'm Stuart Bram's from the
long now foundation I'm particularly
pleased that for this evenings talk
because it gives me a chance to say
something about the magazine that our
speaker works for National Geographic I
was a professional photographer as my
first career way back in the 60s and
venerated from afar the beautiful
photography work and other graphic stuff
and besides the iconic maps that were
coming out of National Geographic and in
the last few years of they've moved that
standard ahead it's still the best in
the world they keep winning best
Magazine Award and earning it they have
a readership those I think four million
something like that currently and
earning it they've gone on to iPad and
are looking beautiful there but also in
the last few years they've brought in
first-rate writers from around the world
and so the writing now is up to the
level of the photography and the
coverage I think of the National
Geographic is right in there with long
now because this is a an entity which
addresses the entire world and through
all time and expresses compelling
stories amazing images and surprisingly
up-to-the-minute news across the board
if you don't subscribe
I recommend it if you have an iPad start
there we get it every month and still
look forward to that little frame of
thing coming in the door well there's
one aspect to the writers and the
photographer's writers and write from
anywhere
the photographer's have to go over there
and they have to work with the locals
and they have to get him immersed in the
story in a way that brings another level
not just photographically but in terms
of the experience the
for and with this very interesting issue
tonight Jim Richardson has been there
and he has stories to tell Stewart
you're exactly right and I and I on the
several points and I appreciate so much
hearing what you said but appreciate
being here with you and with all the
rest of you folks here tonight back in
the day when you were contemplating
being a photographer and I'm glad you
didn't because you probably would have
my job by now I I was at the Topeka
Capital Journal with another
photographer named Chris John she was
now the editor of National Geographic
magazine that you just mentioned and I
remember times of us going out for a
beer with our dog-eared copy of the
Whole Earth Catalog and there was
something fundamental the fundamental
message was that that that everyday folk
could do something do something that
would make a difference and I think that
that was one of the great messages of
our age and and hit as stuck and and
certainly I know it has in my case and I
know that that early influence is
reflected in what National Geographic
does today and what Chris wants it to do
you mentioned something else and and
about about that and I have been a
photographer for National Geographic for
27 years now I think something like that
I think I had I had hair back when I
started I might even have still had
those bell-bottom pants I was wearing
when I was a young turk photographer
back in that in the day and but there is
there's something else about that my
wife and I we live in a small town on
the Midwest now we have a gallery our
pictures are my pictures are on the wall
and we have a very curious thing
that happens and that is that people
come in and they go down the wall and
they're looking at these pictures from I
know
Ethiopia Egypt Cambodia Easter Island
all these kind of they're going down the
wall you know and you kind of see that
they're kind of amazed at all these all
these different locations and I go over
to talk to them and I can hear the
question coming and some one of the the
couple will ask so you take all these
pictures and I said yes I do and then
they say do you actually go I'm not
kidding they do this do you actually go
to all the places you photograph and I
have to say yes that's the way it works
actually yes it is still even in this
age it'll still works that way yes we
actually go well that is the point and
and and in doing all of these stories
that I have done for National Geographic
I actually have to go and that is one of
the great pleasures of it because I've
done a host of stories on water issues
the Colorado River the Columbia River
Mississippi River the old a lot of
aquifer you might not know that one so
well
genetic engineering of food food safety
soil that was you know all the Bill
Allard you know the all these other good
photographers and Nationals year they
get to go and do sidewalk cafes of Paris
you know and I do soil you know and and
I think there's something wrong
apparently with that but this it's the
Lord I've cast for myself because I've
always kind of felt that that there were
those kinds of things that that like
soil that if I didn't do it I wasn't
sure exactly who was going to do it and
I came from a farm so okay that's my
that's my lot and I and I get to go to
wonderful fascinating places but I also
as Stewart mentioned I get to delve
deeply into a subject and I want to what
I want to do tonight is I want to take
you along on this story of
our heirlooms are our combined heritage
of agricultural heirlooms that have come
down to us from 10,000 years of human
endeavor and I was toying about earlier
today with how to begin and and I
thought I would go back and and look at
the story proposal that I originally
wrote for that and when I did that I
thought you know this is probably a
pretty nice succinct way to get you into
the whole thing without mumbling around
a whole lot and but it would also give
you a sense of how these things start
with National Geographic and then how
they progress to fruition and eventually
end up in the magazine so this this is
just the first three paragraphs of the
proposal I wrote that ended up being
this this story this is actually the
second proposal the first one was
written in 2002 and nothing happened and
it was 2008 before we did the story so
you can get some sense of the gestation
period some of these things take one of
the reasons that finally got done was
because former editor Bill Allen left
and new editor Chris Jones came and
Chris I knew had been the State FFA
chairman of Oregon when he was in high
school so I had I had I had a I had a
primed audience there heritage seeds and
breeds our world is facing another
different extinction our heritage of
domesticated livestock and crops without
them and their rich biodiversity built
up over 10,000 years of domestic
breeding we face great danger in feeding
the world's growing population with
potentially could have catastrophic
results generations of painstaking
breeding has produced supreme
adaptations which allowed mankind to
prosper in wildly differing environments
and improbable places intensive
agriculture and its modern incarnation
industrial agriculture striving for high
yields inevitably cast
side diversity in favor of maximum
uniformity and production the danger
comes when new diseases or climactic
disasters threaten our food supply then
The Forgotten diversity becomes
mankind's last lifeline and the possible
loss would be more than just economic
but the loss of one of mankind's great
legacies and and it is this whole
collection of all these thousands of of
breeds of livestock and fowl all these
incredible variety of fruits vegetables
all those things that have come down to
us is one of the great human legacies on
the par with any of our great cultural
legacies anywhere in the world around
the world scientists and farmers alike
are racing to save our domesticated
heritage for future generations
depending on them to feed our ballooning
world population this is a story of that
shared heritage in peril of the people
working to save it and of the richness
and beauty that has been entrusted to us
so that's the kind of thing that I would
write to begin a story for National
Geographic and hopefully somebody there
thinks it's worth doing and then I get
the assignment and a rider would be
assigned and we would go off out in the
field trying to run all this stuff down
so what I'm going to take you on tonight
is a journey along with me on that trip
essentially and to let you go to those
places that I actually did go to take
the pictures and and to share with you
some of the experiences but also the
kinds of the thinking that had to go
into both the production of the story
but also the understanding of the story
and what we hoped to convey to our
readers so starting with that I want to
take you up there where you just saw
that small barred global Seed Vault with
Cary Fowler out there holding seeds out
there in front of that place and to ask
the basic question why are we taking
seeds to
and our to the Arctic why is he standing
out there doing this and as essentially
that's the question that I wanted to
start off this story with is what is
what is the purpose of doing this and
from there to go on to all the rest of
the places you need to understand that
that that Seed Vault is a back up Seed
Vault
it's a Reserve Bank it's a backup in
case of disaster that those seeds which
are duplicates of other seeds in other
seed vaults around the world
if those seed vaults are somehow
corrupted lost or otherwise destroyed
that there will be a backup copy it's
just like a backup hard drive for all of
that of that information and those seed
vaults around the world where we keep
all these things for for active use are
very easily lost actually it's quite
surprising in the war in Iraq one of
their seed banks was broken into by a
mob who promptly dumped dumped the seeds
onto the floor and stole the glass jars
that's all that has to happen all it has
to happen is that your refrigeration
unit breaks down you lose electricity
for three days yeah yeah I mean just all
kinds of things can happen to lose that
biodiversity so we have become very
adept with 10,000 years of agriculture
in our hip pocket of remaking our world
and we have transformed huge expanses of
it to make it into this this lush
productive place to grow food for all of
us seven billion people who we have now
and nine billion who we will probably
have so we have remade places like st.
Mary's Ridge up there in Wisconsin or
Yunnan Province in China to produce vast
amounts of food for billions of people
we have developed these technologies
over the centuries to do it the plow
which is now
and then especially since World War two
with the application of huge amounts of
petrol fuels been able to take that and
automate it to industrialize it to
spread it over vast new stretches of the
earth this is up in the Palouse of
washington and so those basic processes
that you can still see today in some
places you know cutting barley by hand
like I saw in Ethiopia or winnowing
millet in China in the wind have now
been industrialized and turned into this
great mechanized ballet that brings us
all of this food from all over the world
we have taken simple flood irrigation
and turned it into a vastly huge
enterprise that is very much
computerized and automated along the way
we have conspired with the genes of
foods that were productive for us in a
way that had been productive for them so
that if you are a corn gene that is
palatable and savory to humans humans
will then spread you across the face of
the planet to the detriment of your wild
cousins and that is exactly what has
happened so you see corn that was
developed in the Americas now in the
provinces of China we've taken a
poisonous plants like manioc and learned
how to make it nutritious for humans
we've learned the whole panoply of how
to store it against bad times how to
avoid starvation we've domesticated all
kinds of animals dogs 12,000 years ago
by the way as we go through this little
presentation tonight you're gonna see up
there you see dogs 12,000 years ago
that's how long we have been partners
with these plants and animals they are
very much on the same trajectory as us
and we are very much in a dance a
partnership
a conspiracy between the two of us that
is mutually beneficial dogs 12,000 years
ago cattle 10,000 years we've been we've
been working with cattle yeah this is a
we haven't quite domesticated them
entirely yet they're still a nasty Bunch
sometimes about got gored by that guy in
who just sold at the goro cattle market
in Ethiopia chickens goes back to about
8,000 years horses hair seen in the
Sandhills Nebraska about 6,000 years
we've been in partnership with them
camels about 4,000 years lon was about
6500 years one of the few animals
domesticated in the in the Americas so
it's never really had good candidates
for animal domestication very much and
we have made for ourselves a cornucopia
as you can see there at Seed Savers
Exchange up in Decorah Iowa which has
thousands and thousands of fruits and
vegetables available to its members any
members of Seed Savers Exchange that all
good for you all right all right you get
extra points a cornucopia of all this
all this stuff you know and you have to
ask the basic question which when I
initially proposed the story
it's what nagged at me because I was
proposing this story about all of these
heirloom vegetables and and and and nice
livestock breeds and all this without
having the fundamental idea of in my
mind why does this matter why do we
really need all these myriad varieties
of tomatoes and and cucumbers and cattle
and rabbits and all the rest of this
what is the point of having all of this
stuff and why why do we care well first
let me just explain one thing here about
where we were and where we are now so
10,000 years for nine thousand nine
hundred of those years we were building
up variety in domesticated
crops and livestock this whole wealth of
adaptations about specific solutions to
very specific problems crops that would
grow in this specific place efficiently
animals that did well in those
particular hills all that kind of stuff
was a great very precise adaptation to
place in actual economy an actual
efficiency there's little data on how
much we have lost but four nine thousand
nine hundred years we were building that
up and then and then roughly in 1900 we
started throwing it away in vast
quantities throwing it out is about as
fast as we could so just to give you
some idea think take lettuce in 1903
they were in United States there were
497 varieties of lettuce that gardeners
and and and farmers could grow and by
1983 there were 36 left sweet corn there
were 307 varieties 12 left peas 408
varieties 25 left tomatoes 408 varieties
of tomatoes think of that 79 left by
1983 it's a trend notice we're throwing
a little stuff away at vast client
cabbages 544 varieties down to 28
now the actual precise numbers of those
may be varied but the overall trend is
not changed by that at all we are
throwing away vast quantities of all
this here's another way of looking at it
this is the graphic that we did for the
magazine on the top side there above the
line is 1903 that's the bulk of all of
those crops what do we got there
beets cabbage sweet corn lettuce musk
melon okay all right
below
the line 1983 is what we have left that
gives you a graphic weighted sort of
look at how much we have lost so 95
percent gone that's a huge loss so in
what cases do you care why does this why
did this end up mattering well if you
were to go to where some of those grains
came from that we depend upon for
instance Ethiopia many of the
domesticated grains that we depend on
every day you know I went over there to
the green restaurant and had lunch I was
eating wonderful bread they're all that
many of that the grains in that bread
started their life in somewhere around
Ethiopia and Eastern Africa so what has
happened then is those grains then have
been taken all over the world and we
have basically taken prairies and turned
them into bread baskets replacing
perennial greens pray I'm sorry
perennial grasses with another grass
annual grains like wheat and you can
always think whenever you hear anybody
say the word breadbasket what they also
mean when they are saying that is
destroyed Prairie that's that's that's
essential what you what you mean
wherever you go I ate that bread today -
I want that bread basket you know but
that's what we've been we've been doing
and remaking the surface of the earth so
okay so now you've got grains growing
what used to be a poly culture with lots
of diversity now have become a
monoculture with very little diversity
and if you should get a disease that
comes into that that monoculture is
highly highly susceptible for instance
this is one ug99 remember that name
is a wheat stem rust that developed in
Uganda hence the name in 1999 was first
found in Uganda 1999 wheat stem rust
that's what it looks like what the
effect is that when you take that head
of grain and you rub it between your
hands there's no there's hardly any
grain there it's about 80% destructive
to wheat that it infests so this stuff
then starts spreading and is always
spread already spread to Yemen through
the pollen being carried in the wind and
if it gets to India then you're talking
about a country of a billion people
losing 80 percent of its tweet well
that's pretty bad stuff all right
so if that happens then what do you do
about it well here's what you do is you
hope that somebody or in the world has
kept those 200,000 accessions of wheat
that are in seed banks all around the
world and then you go out and you start
growing that wheat and infesting it with
that ug99
and seeing if any of those 200,000
accessions of wheat in seed banks are
resistant and when you find it and you
get it bred into the world's wheat
supply then you start spreading it
around the world to all the farmers and
they start planting this resistant wheat
that's 10 to 20 years if you really work
at it it's very dangerous stuff and this
stuff is spreading around the world I
want to just take a moment here to read
you something when I was modeling around
with this last night I found a quote
about ug99
and this this is just this this is the
arcane world that these guys live in who
do this sort of work Hebert at all
reported that the accession of wheat
cultivar Webster RL 6201 maintained at
the cereal Research Center in Winnipeg
Canada has a locus of resistance to TT
KSK that's ug99 temporarily designated s
our web whatever that means
that map's near sr9 on chromosome to BL
Webster is known to carry the recessive
gene SR 30 on chromosome 5 DL which is
also present in accessioned RL 6201 got
that okay are you keeping up here
conferring resistance to the North
American race TPM k but not to t th KS k
got that interestingly the accession of
Webster maintained at the stiffness the
accession of Webster maintained at the
serial disease laboratory in st. Paul
Minnesota is not resistant to TTA KSK
suggesting that at least these two
exceptions are genetically different so
they thought they had one of those
200,000 accessions of wheat in the seed
bank and they're actually different so
now they got two hundred thousand one x
essence of wheat some of you know so
they're figuring this out as they as
they go along
so does this matter yeah it matters a
lot if you go to the famine Memorial and
Dublin and you think back to that story
of 1846 forty-seven where the Irish
population had ballooned because
potatoes had been brought from Peru and
for a century all this population was
was getting a great deal more food and
the population had grown and then in
1846 a potato blight came in because
there were only two varieties the
potatoes being grown in Ireland and with
and a year and a half a million Irish
people were dead yeah this that stuff
matters because they didn't have the
diversity of all those potatoes you know
to actually be able to have that potato
crop resistant to this one blight these
things happen in our world and ug9 ug99
is one of those things that can happen
so once again how much have we lost 75
percent of agricultural genetic
diversity since 1900 in India 30 to 50
rice varieties survived from 30 thousand
that's a stunning number in it 10,000
u.s. apple varieties were lost in 1900
there were roughly 10 maybe
one thousand apple varieties in the
United States and now there are about
nine hundred you know III had a nice a
nice dessert with a Pippin Apple over
there today and just think about how
many apple varieties are now gone fifty
percent of Europe's livestock breeds
lost since nineteen hundred all of those
were some specific adaptations so so how
did we create this diversity where did
all this stuff come from well as it
turns out the invention of agriculture
was not exactly a direct invention you
don't have to do very much you just have
to take plants and plant their seeds and
you by picking those particular seeds
will automatically do a lot of the work
of the invention quote of agriculture
happened over maybe a thousand years two
thousand years it happened gradually in
a number of a number of places but one
of the places that it happened was corn
corn originally was was came from
teosinte and that which looks like this
and a later mutant version halfway sort
of towards corn starts to look like this
and the century or millennia or so later
you got corn that looks like this and
then for the next seven thousand years
we read corn over and over and we end up
with this incredible variety of stuff
just amazing variety from all over the
world including you end up with this you
end up with a corn that has an
individual husk for each kernel for
crying out loud so think about the
amount of variety that is in all of
these all of these things that we've
gotten how do we save it that's the rest
of the presentation here tonight how do
we what do we do to - well you take all
those corn that's where I photograph
those up there at the north central
plant introduction station in Ames Iowa
and you go in there and you can walk
down the halls and there are tens of
thousands of jars full of corn seeds
from
around
the world and you just store him away so
a seed bank this is what a seed bank
looks like you notice the the film from
inside this fall bard seed bank you know
it looked like a warehouse didn't it
with right house with refrigerator in it
that's kind of what it was you know
that's pretty much all it is and they're
just boxes up on the shelves of steeds
from all over the world about five
hundred thousand of them there or yeah
it's always some sort of cold storage to
keep them vital as long as possible this
is from Seed Savers up in Decorah Iowa
this is out at the National Center for
genetic resources preservation in Fort
Collins where they are doing some
cryogenic storage there's four cryogenic
storage all over the world or may look
just something as simple as that
a farmer cooperative seed bank in
Ethiopia as basically it's jars of seeds
on the shelf but having those when you
need them is key to all of that but you
can't the seeds won't stay viable
forever so you have to grow them out
every every once in a while
varies with the plants some of them
every seven or eight years some of them
ten to twenty years some of them
somewhat longer but you're gonna have to
grow them out and replenish those seeds
with new seeds even up in small Bardon
there's a lemon you can't just stick
them in there and go them back five
hundred years later you're gonna have to
keep recycling those seeds into there so
you have to grow them out see if they're
they will still sprout essentially or
you may have to do this this is what
they do up there in Ames with sunflowers
you can't have bees coming from this
sunflower over here over to this
sunflower and pollinating it so you grow
all your sunflowers in a cage hundreds
of cages all over and therefore you have
to have a beekeeper and he goes around
he takes bees to each one of those cages
to make sure that that that that
sunflower isn't getting pollinated by
its neighbor Apple is a little different
you can't do that you can't just keep
the seeds apple apples have to be
grafted so the basically the only way
you keep apples is you keep the orchard
and you keep growing grafting off of
those all those strange apples these are
not cherries these are apples in an
orchard up there and in Decorah with
about 700 varieties of the 900 left in
the United States and then there's these
curious stories about how things become
preserved Diane weally at Seed Savers
grew at at Seed Savers some of her
grandpa arts morning glories and then
Seed Savers started making them
available to their to their members
grandpa OTT came from Europe brought the
seeds with him from Europe they grow
them out in in Decorah Iowa then they
start making them available when she
goes back home she finds people they're
growing grandpa arts morning glories
because they got them from their seed
bank in Decorah Iowa back in Europe so
they're the whole thing is is rife with
these very particular kinds of stories
and very dependent upon individual
people continuing to grow them out that
is that is highly critical is that they
stay in the culture somehow they have to
be be useful and people that within the
business say you know like with with
livestock you have to eat them to save
them you know if you don't if you if
these breeds have no use to anyone then
they will not be saved so I was
fascinated when I found out that they
had their tomato day came in coming up
at Seed Savers because all of a sudden
they were gonna have like 47 varieties
tomatoes lay down and they were gonna
have all these people going through now
this is photographer heaven when you're
doing a story like this because
somebody's actually going to be doing
something and here were all these people
going through their tasting 47 variety I
actually I hope and hauler in the office
my wife gets used to this I'm over there
doing research on trying to figure out
how to photograph a story like this you
see and I'll get off the phone having
learned that they would have a tomato
day you know man I'm thrilled this is
big-time stuff folks you know love it
yeah so here you know there's just as
these little kind of everyday life
things are gonna happen in front of me
you know and it's gonna tell this story
of this tomato that's what I get juiced
or that they're gonna have yes you know
this is this is growing potatoes I said
I hope I'm right on that potatoes and in
tissue culture potatoes of course you
don't have seeds you can't do that so
you're either gonna have to do tissue
culture or you're going to have to
somehow maintain the diversity at the
location hopefully where they came from
so I want to take you right now to where
they came from in in Peru and because
potatoes are one of those those great
crops that provide vast amounts of food
this is a little map of those centers of
diversity it's the centers of origin of
most of our domesticated crops notice if
you will that the north there Europe
North America Russia all those bread
baskets are pretty weak they are poor in
jeans as they say the South is rich in
jeans that is where this major bit of
this traffic has gone on transferring
genes from essentially the south and
that's an overgeneralization I know from
the south to the north so this is Peru
this is up in the Andes at 14,000 feet
I'm out with a family harvesting
potatoes Antonia and Mariano took me out
there these are potato fields in the
high Andes at 14,000 feet as global
warming continues these potato fields go
further up the hillsides as lower
properties become more valuable for
other crops basically invading areas of
high mountain prairies up there but this
is essentially so in this little field
that you see coming up the valley there
they were going 400 varieties of
potatoes I saw I saw a field of two
acres where they were going 400
varieties of potatoes in one field
altogether you know not in rows divided
altogether you know and it was just we
didn't do that that way in Kansas you
know we had wheat over here and had corn
over there you know and so
means over there no we didn't mix these
things up totally mixed up and which is
where all this variety comes from then I
went back with him where they were
taking them DAC back down to their house
and storing them in piles outside of the
house performing the Papa wata ceremony
which is as a little nice little
ceremony for the spirits of the potatoes
that got left back in the field you know
that the spirits should come down here
you know and and and be part of the
potatoes that that are here it's very
much part of the culture and if you can
maintain the culture you can maintain
the potato because they grow 1300
varieties of potatoes there and they
depend on 30 I'm going to show you just
a just a few of them this was this guy
was a guardian of the potato as a
spiritual leader and basically his his
job in the community was to know the
stories of all these potatoes and what
their uses were and how they how they
fit in so you think you've seen potatoes
well this is there are huge numbers
thirteen hundred I say you know
beautiful odd quirky things they all
have names then they all have stories
you know this this got this potato got
its name from because it looked like a
bull's horn and this potato doesn't die
in frost and it's using it at weddings
and fiestas and this one is for everyday
consumption and this one has the
appearance of a of a whip and that's
where it got its name
and this one's use it weddings and
festivals as well and this one has the
name came from because it ashes of the
soul it's color like kind of the ashes
that come from burning of a body
I don't know that business myself but
they apparently do that that kind of
thing and the the paw of the Puma is it
looks like that you know so multiply
this I'm showing you what eight or ten
of these things carry that onto thirteen
hundred varieties and they all have
names they all have all had uses this is
the great one this one is name it's name
means yeah the the the potato that makes
the mother-in-law cry and the
daughter-in-law
cry because you see it's so hard to peel
that the mother-in-law will be looking
over you see you know it's a so they
they all have names and specific uses
and places in the culture and they are
all very much part of that saving
livestock's is a different matter I went
to the Royal Welsh show because I wanted
to see this that that that that these
cattle who we've been around hanging
around with for ten thousand years have
become part of the family early you know
I mean these I like these guys
stand in there with the cows and I can't
tell who's happier you know they're all
just they're at the fair and they're
having a great time you know and they're
showing off everybody's showing off you
know and they're just just love it you
know or out there our partnership with
horses out there Here I am at then on a
windmill up in the Sand Hills Nebraska
and they're coming in from branding and
they've all gathered around for a little
moment and the horses are sharing the
water you know that the horses feel good
and we feel good and we feel good in
this this partnership we have developed
as a species in partnership with these
animals and they are very close to us
goats for the nine thousand years and
here's this little this this guy out
there waiting for breakfast in the
morning with his goat in his arms you
know I grew up on a farm I remember
holding little Jersey calves in my arms
you know and it was such a wonderful
warm warm feeling you know chickens for
ten thousand years so that a girl out
here in a farm in California you know
can hold that chicken you know and
that's gonna be with her the rest of her
life that those kind of moments of when
she did that you know this woman with
her duck you know she didn't really want
to stop for a photograph but but I got
her too and I'm so glad I did you know
yes she just looks wonderful with her
duck Hanna I just or this girl with a
rabbit rabbits only seven hundred years
when we haven't done a minute along that
but up here in South Dakota and there
she was she was just lost in this this
moment of a summer afternoon with her
rabbits you know and there was something
very touching to me about about that
there are all kinds of species for
instance photographers we've only been
domesticated for about 150 years
and we're not fully domesticated yet so
you know don't let us into the living
room okay yeah these were the folks I
was looking for these are the folks have
made this happen so guys like these
these buyers at the Goro cattle market
in Ethiopia are exactly the same guys as
these guys at the Royal Welsh Show in
Wales they have for 10,000 years
been been looking at all these details
of these animals the curve of the back
of the horse the width of the hooves of
the cattle they the the amount of milk
they can produce on a certain available
forage and when we lose those breeds we
also lose those generations and
generations of knowledge that comes from
these people who have bested on and on
and on so these guys are passing it on
to those kids and they are absorbing it
on Ganic lee as part of our human
heritage and it's a way that the
mechanism happens so yes you have all
these cattle and they are bred for very
specific places like these these Welsh
black cattle were being moved back into
San Adonia National Park up there in
Wales because they could keep certain
kinds of advice if plants at bay in ways
that couldn't be done otherwise but they
also have this nice trait they're very
defensive you know they're nice enough
as long as you don't get around their
calves well that's what you want in a
cow that's out on the hills of Snowdonia
you want somebody who's gonna he's gonna
come after you if you go after the calf
you want say you want that in in the
third world people don't get to maximize
for one variable they don't get as we
have done say in dairy cattle to use
only one breed because it produces
maximum milk they have to have cattle
that will produce meat labor milk and
and and and probably warmth in
the winter you know I mean there there
are all these things that have to have
to come together in order to make a
balanced animal that will be economic
and productive they have to be
multi-purpose and that's a much
different more difficult thing to do
than the simple simple sophisticated
industrial agriculture kind of thing
that we do in the developed world and so
that knowledge those guys have been
watching those those women have been
watching all those generations comes
very much into play about exactly what
kind of animal do we want this is an
interesting recent example the Chicot
are turned out to be resistant to the
diseases carried by the tsetse fly there
were only 24 of them when they
discovered this and now they have
started a breeding program and seeing if
they can transfer that to other cattle
that's a very valuable thing to have in
those areas so all those cattle all
those cattle have their stories to tell
they are all valuable in various places
they are evolved specifically adapted to
very precise worlds and this is what's
been happening there sheep there were 16
hundred and fifty nine total breeds and
181 of those are now extinct and those
sheep wonderfully adapted to all these
particular places I went to Wales and I
went to two different places where they
were raising sheep I went there to see
Lynn Williams and his Hill radner's
because in Wales you know the hilly
Wales so you have sheep that are bred
for the high areas of the hills the mid
area of the hills the low areas of the
hills and and they're all very very
proud of them of course so this is Lin
and his Hill radner's this is a this is
Hugh Evans and his land wenig sheep the
that farm is the number one flock in the
flock booked means that they were
developed right there that you know we
called my friend Jim Turner and I he was
my assistant on this we called Hugh
Hieu the particular because I'm over
there taking pictures of and he's
getting this sheep all lined up you see
for this photograph and he's and he's
looking at the sheep and I go click
click click click and he turns to me he
says there's no use photographing them
if they're not standing right you know
and any judge oh sorry you know and then
we backed off a bit he wants them to be
right it's in his genes he wants them to
be precisely the right sheep and never
to be seen in a bad light you know
that's exactly the whole kind of things
these guys carry hills there's a there's
a town named Kerry and there a Kerry
Hill sheep there these sheep they God
they they they get to eat the lawn you
know these are the kind of sheep that Oh
what's his name
Lord Grantham in Downton Abbey you know
Lawrence a Downton ok yeah ok
he'd have these sheep they're pretty
sheep you know they get to eat nicest ok
these sheep don't these are North
Ronald's a sheep and they get to eat
seaweed you know that's that they live
on North Ronal say you've just four
miles long and two miles wide it's up in
the Orkney Islands and there's a fence
on the island a stone fence and the
purpose of the fence is to keep the
Sheep out on the beach and not let them
on the pasture so force them to eat the
seaweed but think about that these are
sheep who can eat salt water Laden
seaweed and prosper that's kind of a
valuable little thing to have in your
honor your in your in your quiver pigs
711 breeds and 148 are now extinct I
like this particular pig I
I'm the devious photographer you know I
see the farmer he's standing here like
this and the pig is kind of going like
this you know and I thought that's a
nice little ballet between yeah you know
that's that's the way photographers
think you know they were a strange Bunch
we're staying species in ourselves but
that particular breed the Royal white
hogs were born to be long so that when
you had a big litter of pigs the sow
could nurse all those pigs you know sort
of in line no all right this is the kind
of thing these people look for I
remember standing and listening to a guy
talk and and they're in there they're
saying you know talking about sheep and
they see that scene the guy says you see
that sheep over there he's got a he got
that black mark on his left shoulder it
looks kind of like a heart and he says
yeah he says I'll bet you I can move it
to his rump in four generations no I
said you can't you can't know if take
five at least you take five at least you
know you're on you know these guys do
this for sport this is fun you know this
is what we lose if we if we if we lose
not just the breeds but we lose the
people we lose thee we lose the
knowledge chickens are fond of course
there were nine hundred and sixty three
of them and then we've we lost eight 38
or 48 are extinct
yeah Grantham Lord Grantham he'd have
these the silver/gray Dorking you know
oldest British breed you know and they
have five toes rather than four now who
would have thought that five toes on a
chicken yeah these were all taken at
tatton park which is a it's kind of like
Downton Abbey it's a it's a great old
estate farm and they have a great
collection of heirloom chickens there so
yeah all these drains Orpingtons you
know and Hamburg bantams and they and
they all have some particular history
they were raised for some particular
place for some weird reason this is a
black silkie you know this is this is
basically a show chicken you know
there's there's no purpose in having a
chicken like this running around in your
this uh this chicken was he well he was
catatonic is what he was when we were
photographing I mean just never got up
you know I'm sorry you know he probably
looks wonderful
you know if he's if he's right you know
and but look at this guy look at that
the Derbyshire Darby ice let me get it
right
Derbyshire red cap look at that comb on
this guy you know you you know could
just tell when he walked around you know
he's a proud guy you know he really
likes strutting his his stuff this is
the glamorous life of a photographer
back in some back barn you know where we
can find it you know but I was assisted
by the chicken whispers Jim and the guy
there at the farm you know and and and
Jim got really good you know you can
take it put your finger right underneath
the chicken's chin like this you know
and and just raise it up and the chicken
will go hurt and then uh then you go and
they stay there for just a second you
know this is the kind of stuff we learn
to do you know there's yet one more
thing we need to say we need to save not
just all the domesticated ones we
probably need to save huge amounts of
the land races the wild cousins all
these other plants and animals that they
that they came from because if you can't
find like ug99 if you can't find that
resistance in a domesticated variety of
wheat then you're gonna go to the wild
cousins which will make it tougher but
you can do it and if you can't find it
there then you're gonna go to the land
races which will be much tougher but it
can be done and if the world population
depends on it you're probably gonna try
so their goal at Q has been to save 10%
of the world's plant CEC's by 2010 they
reached it in 2009 with twenty four
thousand two hundred species in their
seed bank they concentrate on non
domesticated varieties and it is
absolutely a world resource for wild
relatives of plant this kind of stuff
plants you never heard probably doubles
claw you know devil's claw
but you don't know why it's used to
retreat the pain of pregnancy and also
as a mousetrap in Madagascar I mean we
think we know what we want all this
stuff for you know and then you find
people doing all these weird things all
over the world kappa kpop you know this
was you know that's why were they called
life vests in world war ii cap hawks you
know because it was filled with this
with this stuff african mahogany it's
used to make botanical jewelry you know
Brazil nuts you know Brazil nuts
hey sacred lotus poison castor oil the
bane of all kids in the 1940s and 50s
Looking Glass mangrove beautiful
beautiful things really you know
stunningly look at this stuff a seed
wrap in blue probably the only plant
around that that that that has that and
then this stuff which I thought it was
just the seeds of it were absolutely
beautiful the way this thing pulled
apart and these beautiful transparent
seeds came out it's an anti-inflammatory
you mean all these things they're just
like the diversity that we know of from
the rainforest except except people have
been growing these around the world for
various reasons so finally I want to
take you just on one last little journey
here into Ethiopia to see the crop named
EF I know the TAF is is hardly known the
United States it's grown some you can
probably find it here it's used to make
enduro that bread of Ethiopia anybody
had in Jura you the Fair Mountaineer you
know well you're we're in San Francisco
yeah and out in Kansas I could do that
no no nobody knows and so here we are
harvesting teff there this is a plant
that hardly anybody outside Ethiopia
knows about that is vastly important in
that one particular place this is and
and in its in its and it's wonderful
because it is highly drought resistant
it grows well this is uh so
I followed it through Ethiopia going to
the market where they were selling it
well I eat is [ __ ] when she was
mixing in Jura in her kitchen and then
how yes oaf when she was out cooking it
in this you know there's a little
kitchen out back of the house and then
Jamal Muhammad surprised me he had his
own seed bank he started pulling out
these plastic containers and and ceramic
vessels and he had his own seed bank he
had gone through the starvation and the
famine in the 1980s in Ethiopia he'd
lost family members he knew what what
happened and it wasn't going to happen
to him again and so just in his back
room he had his own seed bank he'd
learned that lesson that like the
intelligent tinkerer you keep all the
parts you you keep those things that can
save you in bad times those women there
on Josiah and sage chef Aaron there at
this farmer seed bank their farmers were
very very proud that they had their own
seed bank that they could take care of
themselves and and have some assurance
that they would survive because these
people who real this is what this is
really about these people this woman
walking home in Ethiopia and she's
carrying seven varieties of sorghum on
her back they grow that many they eat
them directly for dinner that little
girl walking beside her is what three
four she's already learning to carry
home that sorghum on her back you know
it is being passed on right now these
people are very directly dependent upon
it and if we think about it we are too
that's why Cary Fowler is carrying those
seeds into that Svalbard global
Seed Vault that's why we're staying we
need to keep all of those heirlooms for
our future and not just the short term
but the long term and 10,000 years isn't
a bad time to think about thank you very
much thank you for it let's go have a
seat yeah
[Applause]
thanks for going on that journey with me
it's always fun to get back out there
and see you all those those folks kind
of like open up my album we always
envied the National Geographic
photographers and now we know who I
can't wait for your next what is your
next story
yeah it's the next story well I just got
done with the King James Bible know the
tradition probably doing a story on
archaeology Neolithic archaeology in
Orkney or maybe one on
the new interpretations of the Bronze
Age
so Neolithic archaeology means you'll be
looking at them doing their agricultural
revolution or could could be they that
was a that was a fascinating actually
they're up and down to the new west
coast of Europe there are about four
centers of sort of the metropolis of the
Neil at the gauge and Orkneys one of
them and it's just loaded with karyn's
and monuments and stone circles and
villages from from that era and it's a
wonderful place to tell the story of the
Neolithic Age yeah question from George
post in view of the recent reanimation
of a 32 thousand year old plant from
permafrost in northern Russia will we
see a revision of the entire concept of
heirloom species bring back the extinct
whatever it is potato yeah that was an
interesting one today yesterday that
that came about my interpretation of
that was that this was a rare very rare
occurrence that they were able to find
that but yeah the you every once in a
while you're gonna get a chance to do
something like that more important to me
is the large scale of we've got we've
got things sitting in jars in seed banks
that need to be saved there's the
wonderful story by the way of the
Vavilov Institute in in in Russia and
Vavilov was perhaps one of the first
Seed Savers he he's the guy went to
Ethiopia and and mapped out many of
these species and had this great Seed
Vault
in in Russia during the Stalinist era he
fell out of favor with a Stalinist
because he he refused to go along with
their genetic bunk and was off he was
vocally anti Lenko he
as I have the story and and so he gets
sent off to a gulag prison and the the
fascinating story about it is that
during World War two during the siege of
leningrad mm-hmm his staff there at the
seed bank a number of them starved to
death with bags of seed still sitting on
their desk they refused to eat the seeds
because they so believed that they were
saving them for the future that they
starved at their desk rather than eat
the grain were they successful there was
seed seed in fact saved that is that is
the sad part that I was wanting to get
to I have the woman that I talked to at
Ames Iowa said that the sad part is that
today probably half of the seeds in the
babble of collection are no longer
viable and it is simply that whole
expensive difficult business of you got
to keep growing them out you have to
keep replacing the seeds and recycling
them so you say seven to twenty years
what happens it's like after the period
of time I've inserted them down they
won't have once thing that you know that
at 21 years it's no good anymore it's
just that the via the viability Goes
Down and eventually get to the place
that they just will not they will not
grow with this cold health I mean it
totally helps with this particular plant
from 32,000 cold cold helps and that is
why they're they're going into that seed
bank in the in the Arctic is because
they they do they it is naturally cold
freezing back in that mountain and they
cool it further but even if the
electricity goes off mm-hmm
that will stay cold for for a long time
and and aid in the longevity of those
those plants however you have to say
that not all seeds need the same
temperature in the same condition
for maximum storage so this is a bit of
a compromise putting them all into one
vault at one temperature so question
from forest looks like pound what do you
think of efforts to breed perennial
wheat again by crossing annuals with a
nettle perennial grass neighbor I guess
what else Jackson you mentioned him in
here and you're right you're talking
about some of the efforts at least one
of the efforts and that's at the land
Institute in Salina Kansas which is
about 15 miles from where I live
West Jackson right is a MacArthur Fellow
is working on not just wheat but but
perennial grains grains that don't have
to be replanted every year basically
that you could harvest the Prairie and
and so that you you're not plowing all
the time
you're not having all of the erosion
associated with that cultivation and you
get a ideally you would have a
polyculture you wouldn't have just one
one plant mm-hm
so so that you that you have this
natural resistance if you have a dry
year that the dry hardy things come on
if you have a wet year the other ones
come on and and you just harvest the
whole thing it's it's one it's it's one
of the technologies that has great
promise of of answering a particular
problem in agriculture now once has been
blasting away for about 30 years on
those do any of his young staffers they
rated books the San Francisco the great
guy who as has been here and would you
say curmudgeon I would say he comes here
and he says California is so beautiful
god this guy in the weather in the ocean
all that stuff it's easy to find beauty
and color in Kansas you got to work to
find the beauty is not easy but Ruth
okay there is blasting away for three
decades or so surely some
yeah doing this Land Institute so trying
to get the roots deeper and deeper and
there's these beautiful photographs of
perennial plants that they have roots
that go down to their burrows all these
little annual plants are just surface
things well it must be some young
staffers that land Institute or secretly
genetically engineering you mean
actually you know replacing genes
replacing genes and gene splicing genes
slopping all that stuff to get the thing
to happen and a little shorter than 30
years I don't think anybody at the Land
Institute is is doing that but you it's
certainly tempting to to short-circuit
the process I think Wes would tell you
that it isn't necessary by the way by
the way this is a have you ever you know
the genetic engineering world I do we
got drew endy right down here he said
not only genetic engineering you said
you synthetic biology experience this is
kind of fun stuff that I get to do when
I was doing a story on genetic
engineering I always wondered you see
because you know you've you've seen this
this illustration of about genetic
engineering you take the gene from the
jellyfish you know and you put it over
into the corn or something like that you
know and there's no be this arrow right
there's the arrow here's the jellyfish
on the one side of the illustration and
there's a corn on the other side and
there's just arrow you know and I always
wondered how does that arrow work that's
guy that's my job and stories like this
is to figure out how does that arrow
work how do you do that you know so I
went looking mm-hmm and I am and I found
out that there's such a thing as a gene
gun what did you anybody seen a gene gun
II but you you know what a gene gun is
okay they're very cool so and it turns
out that there are 38 caliber gene guns
and 22 caliber gene guns and I'm not
kidding that's great they they go bang
they do you wear your muffs so what
happened was there's there is a
researcher at Cornell who invented this
and he goes into his colleagues office
one day he says it
how much energy do you think it would
take to take this little titanium pellet
cut he's nodding his head I'm on I'm on
the right track coated with genes and
shoot it through the cell wall of a
plant and have it stopped inside the
cell and not go out the other side and
the guys know I don't know but we could
figure it out and so they went and got a
Crossman air pistol and I'm not kidding
and this was the first gene gun and they
put these little pellets inside the
Crossman air pistol and they pump it up
two times and they pump it up for time
and they point it at a potato and and
then what you do of course in this
business is you taking you cut up the
potato and you put that in a petri dish
with and you tissue culture grow it out
you see and and and this is this is the
first one so and and you don't know
exactly how it's going to happen where
the genes gonna go in and so there is a
bit of dicing this year and and so when
I was doing this story I wanted to go
find a gene gun and that wasn't easy you
know but I finally did at Cornell I
found one and it was a 38 caliber gene
gun and I was able to take a take a
picture of it that was a great Eureka
moment for me in doing that story the
Society of the rejection of cruelty to
potatoes you'll be glad to know that
that's still done of course it's one
common way there are other ways but one
has come along and Slowking very
promising is a zinc finger nucleases
where you can basically go in at the
level of a single base pair swap out
this paper and put it on the other base
pair exactly where you're gonna do it
yeah Dean coming along now they don't
have to use a gun anymore but the
inevitable question and Alaska Ellen
Burke asked it how great a threat is
Monsanto to heirlooms that compresses it
depends why it a lot
that depends I bet I mean and I did this
story on genetically engineered foods
and and I was I was a great skeptic at
the time and I still think there are
things to be cautious about and but I
would say that Monsanto is act in in
that regard in that mean that that
question is stated there okay Monsanto
is a much lesser threat to heirlooms
than plain old industrial agriculture
where you the whole dairy industry
depends on about two or three breeds of
cattle the whole turkey industry depends
on two breeds of turkeys you know yes
there there is danger of that for
instance I went up and I I photographed
Oh Percy Schmeiser up in Canada who was
growing oil seed rape and and so I
looked at that very carefully there is
some danger that there is the danger for
instance of well this is Monsanto but
you you genetically modify salmon as
they as they do you know and then the
salmon get out and the modified gene
takes over from the wild gene and all of
a sudden you don't have any wild salmon
salmon left and that can happen
relatively cool okay so there are there
are definitely things to be worried
about in the context of heirlooms you
know we've already seen the boogeyman
and and Monsanto in that realm is a
minor boogeyman compared to other other
processes so there's a version that
question crystalline Barney asks do you
think genetic engineering is helping or
hindering future diversity I was talking
with Drew endy of you know in the decade
of the next genetic engineering is
coming into the Gardner's yet it's
already in the garage it is yeah and you
know one of the things you showed with
heirlooms is vast and wild
rambunctiousness and and just
amazingness people want to make potatoes
look as weird as period as weird so
they've been doing that
we view the long hard process of
breeding presumably they're gonna go
totally bananas as soon as they can
start doing it gene by gene yes but you
have to go get that gene someplace there
you go you you still need that that bank
of seeds because we're not we're not
quite that clever yet to figure out how
to to do the trait we want we generally
still go back in that seed bank and we
and we we get a hold of that that gene
with a certain trait and we and we don't
invent it ourselves we we find it and
insert it and and in that regard
actually the whole business of
understanding and this is a very complex
field to understanding where all that
diversity is and collecting more of it
you see because like cue cue is out
there still collecting you know the
people are still go out and looking for
wild land races and and wild cousins of
crops and and everything that is
actually increasing the amount of
diversity we have at our disposal not
not the actual amount of diversity but
the amount that we have at our disposal
so in that regard if if those genes
become valuable and more money goes into
the search then then that increases
diversity so I that's a wishy-washy
answer but that's as good as hearing
again well it's I said one of our
previous speakers was pamela ronald who
works with rice at UC davis and genetic
engineer and she's developed a rice that
holds its breath underwater for two
weeks so it's a flood tolerant right
where'd she get the genes to do that
they got it from a wild ass variety of
no didn't come from around where shark
or something like that comes from
another variety but it could but it
comes from another variety of rice that
was preserved that was not particularly
tasty it was a whole different part of
India than Bangladesh with the for the
example where the floods are but because
it was preserved they were able to get
this flood tolerance and they were never
able to breed it into the really tasty
rice but there wasn't hard to basically
a precision breed of the genetic
and now they have this flood tolerant
tasty ricin is taking off in Bangladesh
good story it's a story that combines
genetic engineering and this kind of
banking that I think is what really
almost always happens there's a good
question from Laura well-stirred saying
that saving the world's heirloom seems
dependent on saving their knowledge
about them they're named stories uses
show that what's going on where these
landraces are which by the way means
saving languages and cultures and things
which are pretty fragile and are
themselves often going extinct how do
you deal with that the example the place
that I went in Peru is the potato park
and parque de la popa I hope I'm saying
that closer to right and and basically
what has happened there is that there
are seven villages that in this valley
that have gone together and and made a
concerted effort to bring back the
potatoes they were down to about four
hundred varieties of potatoes but many
of their varieties of potatoes had been
saved to a seed bank down in Lima I
think that's right lima and now they're
being brought back back to that that
valley that is a is a prime example of
yes how you have to save the culture as
well as the stories and the language in
because if there's no and if there's no
one who actively uses those potatoes
there's going to be no one who grows
them stupid town and corollary but it's
exactly that is exactly the case and
it's why people in in the livestock you
say the RB is the Royal Society for
preservation of breeds RSPB says a you
have to eat them to save them you they
have to be actually useful to someone
and and in that regard then you have to
do things like you have to have butchers
who who will cut them up for you because
you know large-scale packing plants are
really disassembly plants and they only
want specific
breathes you know they want a they want
steers that have bones of a certain
length because they're set up to
disassemble those factory cows you know
so if you if you're going to raise these
breeds you not only do you have to say
you say you say the language and the
culture and all that you have to have
people who will butcher them who will
market them who will you know all those
all those kinds of things yes so at Lisa
bartlett that wonders what can we do to
be saving these various things it sounds
like we have these whatever the cow is
find it yeah well that doesn't hurt yeah
actually it doesn't hurt you know so I
would say the first thing is be smart be
smart
you don't actually necessarily have to
do anything but when when some stupid
politician wants to cut funding for
these seed banks because why the hell
are we saving 200 thousand varieties of
wheat when they only need one you know
you can be the person who stands up at
that town-hall meeting and says wait a
minute it doesn't work that way I mean
that's that's the first thing if you
want to do something actively go join
Seed Savers or native seed search or
something grow them out you know one of
the reasons that Seed Savers has all
these these plants is that their members
have been growing all these vegetables
in their gardens that is it is such a
it's such a wonderful example of
community citizens participation in the
effort so are these is this seed that
you mentioned members so there's they're
members of this seed saver organization
they were yeah and they get the seeds
and they grow them and then they save
the seeds and send the back and all that
right and you in and being a member
means that you share your seat so you
you're going out these well grandpa
Ott's morning-glories or whatever and
and you're collecting seeds and those go
back to the Seed Savers Exchange and and
made available to other members the
catalog is wonderful I mean all the
course aren't oral seed catalogs
wonderful you know really you know I
mean is such a optimistic time of the
year it
[Music]
that's how you get through the winter I
was leading those colorful seed catalog
new fresh person healthy and cultured
and but yeah I mean there are these
wonderful varieties of things and there
are there are and there are a number of
these organizations around and and so if
you're not in the Midwest there might be
heavier on that there's some new New
England there in the southwest you know
you can you can find them that have the
kinds of things that you want and and
and it's a core pretty different yeah so
this is one of the many in the none
either one or if you the many people
that are growing these various seeds and
swap them among themselves you can do
that too you do find that that breeds
are kept alive and just exactly that way
in innumerable varieties of vegetables
are here because somebody brought the
seeds with them when they came over from
the old world so this raises the
question of soil can you talk about soil
seed interaction native soils are also
in decline I'm not sure what that means
if you think the soil is the womb of the
seed is that an issue here you did that
the whole story on soil it's the
relation of soils in landraces yeah
and and that's that's another that's
another great realm of you know these
issues that are critical but generally
seen as boring you know and our
understanding of what's going on in the
soil is is poultry frankly we don't know
what's what's going on we don't know how
it works if we if we if we think we
understand that we need water and we
think we understand that we need we need
clean air then then go back down to the
level of soil and and and think that all
life on Earth depends on this stuff that
is only a few inches to maybe if you're
lucky a few feet thick I mean just this
top which is actually some sort of and I
believe so
sort of living organism some sort of
living productive being and and we we
have to not only do we have to have it
if we are going to prosper for the long
term and I think you're in that business
we've got to get better at it you know
and we we not all do we have to preserve
it we have to figure out you know what
we have been doing that has been so
destructive and stop it and and then and
then how to be better partners with it
and not simply ignore it
famously historically many culture is
gone
many Empire has gone down when they yeah
you stuff their soil you know the
tragedy that going on in Syria today is
echoed because I've been there there are
the dead cities and in that area around
Aleppo which were a hundreds of
abandoned villages and small towns and
cities there and as in Byzantine times
they were flourishing communities and
now they are surrounded by karst
formation stone which basically means
that there was topsoil there only what
thirteen hundred years ago something
like that yeah and it's all going you
know there are those stories all over
the world the burn of the burn of
Ireland have you been to Ireland that's
another one question from Owen does
permaculture and I guess polyculture
contribute to plant animal diversity
better than monoculture do you see
things moving in that direction away
from monoculture toward what's called
permaculture or polyculture you saw a
lot of that was anything's better than
monoculture yeah there you are
non-cancerous come on you're gonna do
polyculture in Kansas no we're not
burning Iowa but but oh you can't
address it this question as stated is is
implying that it's either permaculture
or monoculture monoculture meaning yeah
you do wheat from from
from from my home to Western to the
border of Kansas you know and it's all
the same variety and all that that's and
but there there is vast territory
between that extreme and and
permaculture which is a very particular
kind of I'm traipsing on my ignorance
here of saying that it's organic
necessarily but yeah and then then
there's a whole range of options in
between and and yes I mean but but
basically the most fundamental things is
there are stupid ways of doing things
and smart ways of doing things even if
you're doing monoculture there are
smarter ways of doing things and the the
real profit comes from getting smarter
you're here a final question from Bruce
did you find any new food types just
beginning the journey to acceptance and
I don't know that I can answer that
question exactly but but one of the
interesting things about this is that
all virtually all of those domesticated
breeds of particularly grains but and
livestock that we depend upon were
developed by Neolithic people Stone Age
people virtually none of them there are
there are just virtually no examples of
modern agriculture with all its wonders
domesticating anything new and that's
really quite quite surprising almost
everything that we depend upon was done
and you saw the years four thousand to
ten twelve thousand years ago and we
have domesticated virtually nothing new
since that's quite a quite a testament
to ok so let's pick a name those people
living at that time what animal would
you like to domesticate I mean I would
say magazine editors there
no hope someone knows about animals to
domesticate you know they're working on
domesticating foxes funnily enough that
just came to my mind what's what's the
idea they're an if your kind of dog why
is it gonna see if we all figure out how
to do it but it is interesting that that
that they that people have pet foxes now
my god
I mean they've basically figured out you
know the breeding to to take a a wild
Fox and make it a domesticate that
probably is one of the new rare examples
of a new domesticated breed I think
mom's Lions what do you think probably
not precision breeding you probably
there you know tabby cat put it in the
mouth lion and now you got I'd once
lived to the cheetah who is friendly in
Africa and oh yeah being with a large
cat who's per you can hear from a
hundred feet away right and which you
know roars behind your head when you lay
with your belly I think large cats are
going to be retracted
I'll say we had domesticate always and
you know trained them to go after the
rodents in the garden there you go yeah
that would be helpful and interesting
things to do at night with your all's I
you know curiously as they I'm a
forecaster by trade I fur cast in this
decade to our mixture of delight and
horror we were gonna see new
domesticated animals some of the for
food but mostly for delight I think
curiously if you if you look at cheetahs
you mentioned cheetahs and you have all
probably seen this these wonderful
pictures of cheetahs that are up on the
hood somebody's out there and they're in
this in this Land Rover out there and
there's a cheetah up on the hood okay
there was one family of cheetahs that
was raised I'm kidding I'm not getting
there there was one family of cheetahs
that was raised and that particular
family of cheetahs is in virtually all
those pictures but there there you go
it's just in in in in more general terms
I think one of the great lessons is is
this is this is not something where we
necessarily have to reinvent the wheel
we have to not throw away the wheel and
and there are things that we need to
solve new problems this is not
necessarily we need to solve a new
problem we need we need to keep the
answers that we already figured out so
what I like and we're gonna have a talk
surely from Edward or Wilson who
invented the term biodiversity in a
sense you're making the case for
agricultural biodiversity and that
sounds like such a damn clear attractive
goal that we all want to help thank you
are you better thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]